we have something very
exciting to discuss right now one of us
i won't say which of us it could be matt
gorley it could be conan o'brien or it
could be sona obsession one of us is
about to be
a published
author
i can definitively say it's not me
right i'm not even a published reader
[Laughter]
i'm not sure how that joke works but
we'll do so we'll do some uh triage on
it and figure it out sona this is
exciting you have a book coming out tell
us what's the book called it's it's
called the world's worst assistance yes
yes i love it finally vindication it is
i have to say out of the three of us it
is shocking i'm the only one who wrote a
book i'm not even no it is especially
conan with you because you're i'll get
there someday
yeah let's focus on the book yeah you've
written a book called
the world's worst assistant yes
and it chronicles what sona it
chronicles my time as your assistant yes
thank you
and uh i have to say
i read the book my wife read the book we
both thought it was spectacular
you're very honest
there are some real you are quite honest
in this book about the ways uh in which
you took advantage
of my uh of my kindness and idiocy um
to make that job
um a boondoggle for you and and you give
great advice for how people can emulate
you well i i think first when i first
started writing it i think uh i thought
oh am i gonna make conan look bad and
then when i was done with the book i
made you look great and i made myself
look horrible
and i think that's that well no i do i
look i look
terrible i think that there's a lot that
i have gotten away with but i think it's
a credit to you because especially now
there's a lot of conversation about like
shitty bosses and you
are not a shitty boss i think the fact
that i could make fun of you and say
things to you means that you're not a
shitty oh people will read this and go
what was his problem why didn't he fire
her a long time ago
this guy was asleep at the switch
now you know i have to say it it is uh
it is very well done the book is really
well done it's really funny um and
there's some real sweet parts in it too
and uh i was very impressed your husband
does the artwork for it and it's really
good and funny very funny he made you
look really uh
pathetic yes
i spent hours posing for him
he really captured
my complete ability my complete
inability to uh establish order in a
workplace yeah i did think of how how
would i want to write a book that i
would want to read and i realized i
would want cartoons in a book so i just
put a lot of cartoons and illustrations
in mine and pictures and i wrote the
forward and you wrote the forward which
is clearly just the strongest best part
of the whole it's a really good thing
yeah but i mean it's you know and i talk
about how my book peaked
at the forward and i think it's
very true i have a prediction that fans
of this podcast because i'm constantly
meeting people
who listen to the podcast they always
ask me
and it's funny i used to get this a lot
when i would for years and years and
years when i was doing the late night
show or the conan show
wherever i was i could be anywhere in
the world and people would say where's
andy
they thought that we traveled together
and
you know if i walked into a men's room
they didn't know why andy wasn't with me
to take the urinal uh you know
to my right
which is the position he's supposed to
be assuming and it's the same thing now
because of the podcast i go places and
they go like well where's sona where's
matt i go well i'm taking the you know
family on a vacation
in tahiti why would i take them with me
but they
they insist that you guys must be
somewhere but i think uh fans of the
podcast are going to really like the
book i i do talk about the podcast
because i think
uh
you know this is very nerve-wracking
sometimes you guys have done this a lot
like you guys have you've you've
performed in front of people you've done
so many podcasts but i think i'm the odd
man out having never done it and it's
very it can be very nerve-wracking but i
do talk about how
i became a national speech champion and
that after that everything else just
didn't did it matter
what age did you become a speech
champion
come on no i'm serious i'm i'm asking i
was 20. you were yeah when you were you
were 20 in college in college in college
you won a national speech championship i
did and i remember when i first hired
sona about it months after i hired her
you dropped that you had been a national
speech speech champion and then
every time you and i would get into an
argument you would bring it up like
hey wait a minute i'm a national speech
champion i'd say
i know what does that have to do with
the fact that you you embezzled 35
or you fed gummy worms into the printer
as a as a prank what is that i was a
national speech champion i like that
instead of the world decided that you
peak too soon you proclaim i peaked then
that's exactly right takes the pressure
off yeah yeah and i do mention how out
of the podcast my friendship with matt
gourley started and how that's my
favorite part about it oh my god that's
really nice yeah but also you know
you're
you commit crimes
don't know what you're talking about and
by the way let's keep the focus on you
no i mean one of the questions is
doesn't the world's worst assistant
have the world's worst boss possibly
possibly no i you commit crimes of
course you've allowed this to happen i
allowed it to happen i always thought
even at its very worst i always thought
our interaction was so funny and comical
it was we were living out a sitcom of
the ass everything was so upside down
yeah but with in in our relationship as
assistant boss
and you know we live in this world now
where people are trying to codify what
does that mean
um rules in the workplace and you and i
always had a completely absurd
relationship to one another
and it and it got to the point where i
thought this is great
this is more important
than us
setting the right example for people in
the world uh this is just too funny and
i think it's been borne out over time
because and i think one of the things
that helps a lot is you're always you
you're always you and that's what i like
about your book is that your book is
very
honest and it is really a reflection of
you
um some of the things that you do that
you describe in the book
may be criminal
uh
did you check the statute of limitations
on any of these but it's all done with
love it's all but done with uh love and
a real joie de vivre and i think that's
what makes it so much fun yeah so i i'm
encouraging people to check out the book
i'm excited for it to come out
and um excited for people to read
just what you've done that's true it is
very true a lot of it is has been a lot
of fun and it's it's been so much fun
being yours tonight i love it and i'm
going to do it till i die i'm just going
to
ride those coattails forever that's true
just use those perks one of my favorite
pictures that we had in the in the old
office
uh was we were at we were doing some
event and it's me taking selfies with
about 900 people yeah in the background
and you're in the foreground not helping
me at all
drinking the largest pour of chardonnay
you've ever seen someone put half
someone put half a bottle of chardonnay
into a glass and you are enjoying it so
much and i'm in the background working
my ass off there it is i love that photo
there it is there it is
oh there it is oh and look at your face
your face is kind of like
i hope he's okay
oh my god
we got to post that go to uh team coco
instagram we're going to post version of
it yeah but it is and uh team coco
podcast instagram so tell us when this
book is going to be out and where people
can get it this book comes out july 19th
comes out tomorrow right and it's
available everywhere your independent
bookstores your amazon your barnes noble
i mean it's everywhere gas stations
uh airport kiosks okay i don't know i'm
just saying things now i don't know
where to buy books
i didn't think you did
that's why it's shocking i brought one
well congratulations
the book again is called the world's
worst assistant and forward is written
by you and uh the book by sonam of ceci
by me and uh art by by takberoy and my
husband very cool congratulations
congratulations